[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun
really excited to be talking about this
this is a thoughts on Amazon's HQ - it's
all over the news right now it's likely
going to go down as one of the biggest
decisions made by the biggest company
one of the biggest companies in the
world and it's a major economic decision
for the areas that Amazon's moving into
and this is huge news and it's huge to
talk about so we're gonna unpack it in
its nuance for you so again this is not
about it being good or bad this is about
the new wants the new wants the multi
variability there's so many variables
trillions of them to talk about so this
is not a binary concept get that in our
souls not binary ok so moving into this
we have now seen Amazon turn into what
it's become over the last 20 years going
from just being books and selling those
books and moving them through an online
e-commerce platform that could host as
many books as you walked instead of the
limited amount of books you know in a
bookstore - now selling home and kitchen
- selling toys and games - selling
things in healthcare - selling all
different types of stuff and being a
massive trillion dollar company that
bought whole foods that has Amazon Web
Services that has AI Amazon Prime that
has third-party selling goods through it
is absolutely nuts how large this is the
only other thing that competes with
Amazon on the planet is Alibaba and
Alibaba is like the Amazon of China and
of Asia distributing goods there and
soon to be also
distributing goods to Africa that is a
separate conversation and we will need
to do some thoughts on the China Africa
relationship soon but that is one of the
growers growing economic markets in the
world so let's unpack some of the nuance
of what has happened so I want to show
you the locations that were decided on
for Amazon's HQ - this is kind of
interesting because as Amazon's growing
and becoming this massive behemoth of a
company they have the privilege of
saying 13 months ago they said all right
we're gonna pick HQ - so what happened
was a bunch of cities 238 cities decided
to submit tax incentives cash incentives
for Amazon to pick their City as the
city to host HQ - in and it's very
interesting that it's basically the top
of the socio-economic strata Jeff Bezos
and Amazon basically having all of these
cities across the United States be like
please please please pick us we want
that thousands of jobs we want the
billions of dollars of incentives and
then and then for them to basically have
all these options this this massive pool
of ideas from these different cities
about where they would want the HQ to go
why would they would want it to go there
how they would structure the economic
incentive plants and economic
development plans in those area so now
amazon has this pool of 238 applications
for how to develop these cities which is
again it's just it's genius to be able
to you're basically crowdsourcing the
most innovative plans across the United
States again this is very much so like
an XPrize model of crowdsourcing the
brilliance into trying to find the best
ideas now there has been a lot of
criticism for the decision that was made
because the decision that was made was
to put it in New York and Washington DC
New York City Washington DC now when you
put it in these two all
ready major hubs on earth on in the US
what it's saying is that these other
sort of cities such as maybe Denver or
Dallas or Chicago or wherever else was
just not as important as these other
cities which is how some people are
taking it and I think it's important to
recognize that Amazon's not gonna come
to my hometown of Sioux Falls South
Dakota to build HQ - that's not in their
best interest they're not gonna build it
there to try and make that economy
bigger rather than go to New York City
go to DC where there are already a
tremendous amount of intellectual nodes
they're diverse intellectual people from
around the world live there already and
they can hire the smartest people to
work at HQ - such as their pushes in
artificial intelligence but also now I
want to make a distinction there's a
difference between a warehouse employee
for Amazon and a difference between a
headquarter employee for Amazon when
you're headquarter employee for Amazon
you're working at this HQ - you're on
artificial intelligence scientist you're
a programmer you're a designer these are
the people that Operations specialists
that live there that try and refine the
supply chain all that type of stuff they
work at the headquarters they get paid a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
dollars a year these are the best of the
best in terms of what their abilities
are versus when you work at a warehouse
and this is you know this is your
classic like these are your classic
warehouse photos you know here's a photo
of one of their distribution centers and
this is them going absolutely nuts with
you know with robotics and with the
proper equipment and mechanisms that
make it easy for them to distribute
goods at the scale that they do and
here's another you know photo these guys
in this photo are not getting paid 100
or 200 thousand dollars a year the guys
in this photo are getting paid somewhere
around $30,000 a year about $15 an hour
across the United States is somewhere
around the average and so when it comes
to the distinction between those two I
think it becomes more and more important
for us to understand that that they're
picking to move to these locations in in
one of the variables
because of the high density of very
smart people that already live in these
areas they want to turn Washington DC
into a major hub they want to turn New
York City into a continued turning New
York City into a major hub in DC into
major hubs and that's why I doing this
East Coast West Coast dominance in the
United States and that's becoming a
reoccurring theme in many lights so I
have a bunch of interesting information
that I want that I want to drop us as we
go the economists and other sources have
been trying to parse as many sources as
possible in synthesize information down
into this relatable substrate for as
many people as possible it's somewhere
around 44 cents of every dollar spent
online in the United States is spent on
Amazon the amazon's crushing it due to
their speed inconvenience their vast
network of warehouses and logistics and
automation so there's about 125,000
full-time amazon employees in the united
states 75 fulfillment centers and then
there's 500,000 amazon employees
worldwide and this includes things like
stores pickers and packers so Stowers is
the people that go and store the
supplies when they're running out and
stock the supplies pickers are the
people that go and get the notification
and say that okay I got to go get this
thing then they go grab the thing and
give it to the Packers which then go and
package the thing pickers are crazy
because they can collect up to a
thousand items and walk up to 15 miles
per shift now when I read these numbers
I think about okay this is a hard job
this is a lot of work working in an
Amazon warehouse can be a decent it's
not necessarily the most creative work
you're not making new ideas and making
new designs but what you're definitely
doing is you're working quite hard on
being able to do this so too do they
deserve to get to get paid well if
everyone deserves to get their selves
paid and their selves to be a team or
actualize their families to be taken
care of how do we do that with the
largest companies in the world we
haven't figured out the exact way to
calculate all the variables and figure
it out but this is at least the
conversation around how what's going on
half of the
employees that work at the fulfillment
centers are under the age of 35 and earn
about 30,000 a year about 14 bucks an
hour and many people have been quoted
saying that these are the locations that
are being left behind so Amazon's going
into some of these places that are left
behind in building fulfillment centers
and therefore increasing jobs I mean
hundreds thousands of jobs in these
specific economic ly developing the
economies in the areas that have many
have said are left behind with people
moving out to the coast so a quick
breakdown on revenue a lot of people
think that Amazon Web Services is a
major component of the revenue it's less
than a 10 percent of the company's
revenue about nine percent or so whereas
sixty-seven percent comes from retail
sales and 17 percent comes from
third-party retail sales Prime's about
five percent so it's crazy because
Amazon's
looking to be making around 200 billion
dollars a year in revenue which is
absolutely nuts that's so much money and
that comes out to about five hundred
million dollars a day in revenue it's
crazy and a lot of people have said that
you know the reason why one of the major
reasons why also is because of customer
service because of just how well they
treat people in terms of the people that
are purchasing their products and
services so I want to I want to make
this really clear that I I have a very a
very hmm I want to I want to I want to
immerse us into the shoes of what it
would be like to be Jeff Bezos and the
people that are choosing that are
getting to choose where to put hq2
because really when you get these
applications from these 238 cities and
you're sitting there and you're looking
through this ideal list and you're
getting the pick isn't it also
interesting that at any point they can
say let's say nine months in they say
let's do it in New York and DC that's
our final decision at that point before
they release that information to the
public they can go and spend four months
of time looking and buying the
properties in that area they can go and
start investing private money with
insider information into these different
hubs
the public even knows about it so this
is how money makes money rich get richer
and that is how in many ways information
in knowledge around what's going on with
the largest companies in the world and
what they're doing is a huge key for you
to also go and make money in that sense
so this is separating this is a big deal
between the haves and have-nots you
either have the knowledge of Ramazan
going or you don't have the Najma where
amazon's going now one may say well how
do you know that that day that they went
and surveyed the land and invested in
the properties and did all that I'm not
saying I know I'm hypothesizing that
this happened and I'm saying it's much
more likely that this happened then they
just said okay New York and DC and then
in n Tennessee for Nashville and then
just announce it to the public the next
day and didn't do any investing and
curating into those areas ahead of time
so all food for thought around how the
money makes money in so many ways and
that that knowledge is so incredibly
important for you as you move into the
world and try and figure out oh where
should I position myself well you should
position yourself where the freaking
knowledge is because that's what's going
to help you move forward all right so if
we can actually have maybe a log we
could find some objective information
about this of what property was
purchased by what groups in the last 13
months in DC in Long Island in sorry in
Crystal City in Long Island City and in
Nashville those three places if you
could find a log of the last 13 months
of properties purchased there and real
estate purchased there then you would
have a more objective understanding of
what's actually going on in I would
challenge us to be able to figure that
out so I do say that this is some of the
best talent and some of the best ideas
to split it rather than concentrating it
in just New York or DC to split it like
this and add some in Tennessee as well I
think is a very interesting idea there's
going to be tens of thousands of jobs in
economic development that comes up
tremendous economic
unity and so there have been some
critics and I'm gonna talk about the
economic development a little bit so
there's been some some people that have
said amazing amazing you know New York
City is already excited to to increase
the subway routes and the bus routes and
the tunnel systems and the metro area
transit systems like amazing amazing
that's gonna be great and Amazon could
again this is a could be Amazon could
really help with libraries and they
could help with universities they could
could they could commit resources to
things like affordable affordable
housing in the areas this is totally
true but this is a could be for now this
is not a fact yet so we hope this is
what's gonna happen with the economic
development so that we are very sure
though of certain things which are that
there's gonna be more condo buildings
built in those areas there are going to
be higher standards of living in those
areas what is a standard of living based
on spirituality or happiness
where's a standard of living based on
the amount of money that you earn and
then the amount of money that you
contribute to your local economy how are
we currently variables so there is
something very interesting about the
contribution to local businesses if you
go into Long Island City or Crystal City
and in Virginia and let's say that you
start living there and working at the
Amazon headquarters again much different
than the Amazon warehouse so you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year now
remember that you're gonna eat at the
cafeteria every single day for lunch
five meals out of your day you're gonna
be eating and potentially ten meals of
your day cuz you're also going to be
eating dinner there so that means that
ten meals potentially every single day
you are going to be eating at Amazon
that means those ten meals are not gonna
be spent at the Crystal City or at Long
Island City businesses and these are the
things that are being promised but guess
what when you need to buy a hammer when
you need to buy a pair of jeans when you
need to buy some socks we need to buy
some laundry detergent all this kind of
stuff you have to shop at the local
businesses in those areas so is there
gonna be economic stimulus
absolutely yes will it necessarily be by
food hmm
not the 10 meals per week that they're
gonna be eating the five days Monday
through Friday so the food is likely
sourced from local vendors in the area
and one not at least some portion of it
is so at least there is that there is
potentially some food contribution in
that sense so now here are some of the
things that you know that skeptics have
said and I agree with these points these
points are extremely valid points the
fact that there is going to be a
significant amount of displacement when
you go and put up these derivative the
big condos in the areas that I'll have
that are going to be three thousand four
thousand dollars a month in rent in
these different places that you are
going to have people that can no longer
afford the housing that they've lived in
for decades because those housing prices
are going to increase landlords if they
don't have rent control if the if the
tenants don't have land control
landlords can increase the prices and
that that the tenants can no longer
afford so if a single bedroom in these
areas is now two thousand dollars a
month or more we're going to have
significant displacement these people
aren't making a hundred thousand a year
they're making ten bucks an hour
twelve fifteen bucks an hour in these
areas so they can't afford these drastic
rent increases that are occurring in
their areas due to headquarters moving
in we have to remember that that's a
really important thing to remember the
other things that have been neo prop
that have not yet been completely
promised are things like will amazon
hire locally so will they actually hire
in these areas or will they have people
fly in from around the world to work at
these places also what are the jobs that
will be hired for if they do hire
locally how much will those employees
get paid and what will those benefits
actually be so these are the pressing
questions that we actually need to ask
to know about the actual development of
the communities in the areas of Amazon's
moving into I want to know more about
the actual economic calculation of
providing Amazon with these hundreds of
millions of dollars in cash and tax
benefits because it's it's kind of
interesting when you think about it
if you give a company so many millions
of dollars in tax benefits and cash
benefits for them to come to build their
headquarter in your area over a period
of five 10 20 years likely after after
that long yes you will have your economy
will have made that money back
what about how happy people are what
about how spiritually inclined people
are what about how strong the
communities are we don't measure these
variables these are very difficult
variables to actually measure and so if
we were to start measuring that what
would moving a headquarter into a
community do would it increase the love
in the community and the standard of
living would it decrease it how do we
know these things how do we measure
these variables so I'm very interested
in that again this disparity amongst the
economic shifts that are going on on our
planet is something that we must talk
about where we have a single trillion
dollar company deciding we're gonna move
headquarters in this location the
economy's there explode and then other
economies and people are potentially
left behind that this needs to be a
global conversation about what we're
doing with wealth inequality across the
world we talk about that so much last
point hasn't come to a close we have to
remember what's happened in San
Francisco very recently there was a
proposition prop C to figure out how to
take businesses that are making so many
billions of dollars every single year in
revenue and tax them so that we can help
figure out the homeless crisis that we
have in San Francisco and in New York in
all these different places and so Marc
Benioff was a major proponent of prop C
where as Jack Dorsey from Twitter was
majorly against it
there were several tech CEOs that were
very against prop C and I don't know
enough about the nuance of the
proposition but what I can say is that
Marc Benioff has now invested into the
Children's Hospital San Francisco he's
been a major advocate for philanthropy
he's a huge philanthropist himself you
know Mark Zuckerberg himself is also a
huge philanthropist in many ways part of
the Giving Pledge and it's just very
strange to me that out of the suppose
it's 70 Billy 7
billionaires in the san francisco bay
area 7-0 billionaires here that why is
it just Mark Zuckerberg and Marc Benioff
that are that are so avidly
philanthropist what's going on
why why does Marc Benioff make it so see
make it she's literally cult billion
herself for hoarding their money is what
he said what do you what what meaning
and fulfillment do you get in life from
having a third yacht or from having a
third car or having a third home what
does that do for you when you're in your
empty mansion on a Sunday night what
does it do for you when you invest in
two artists thirty thousand artists
giving them each a thousand bucks or ten
thousand bucks what would that do for
you what would I do for the world how
much more meaning would that give your
soul we have to figure out how what
we're gonna do moving forward because
issues like this are arising now where
tech giants are coming to major cities
and they're flourishing the economies
but what are they doing about the crisis
of the community and the crisis of
homelessness that's going on in those
areas and the crisis of displacement
that comes from that how can we find the
right balance and right equilibrium with
what's going on with that we desperately
want to figure that out here on
simulation and that's why we unpack the
nuance of what goes on join us in
unpacking the nuance of these
conversations the amazons hq2 is just
one of so many things that we unpack the
nuance on on this show we need your help
help stop having binary conversations
these are not yes or knows these are not
black or white these are nuance there's
trillions of variables to calculate at
the same time and to figure out what's
the best solution moving forward when
you hold just your perspective just your
lens on something you lose what it looks
like to have the lens of someone that's
poor or middle-class or rich you lose
the lens of looking at it from someone
that's black or someone that's Asian or
someone that's white you lose the lens
of looking at
from someone that's old or someone
that's young or someone that's
middle-aged remember how many
perspectives there are on every single
issue enshrine absorb as many of them as
possible to get as close to the truth as
possible join us in this movement for
nuance to rebirth the public
intellectual we greatly appreciate you
tuning and let us know your thoughts
below in the comments we'd love to hear
from you and please join us we need to
scale and continue impacting the patreon
and kur cryptocurrency links are below
please join us in this movement thank
you Ron our producer and director much
love to you much love to Sarah for
joining us in this session as well as
assistant Thank You huge thank you much
love everyone and we'll see you soon
peace
[Applause]